[Applaudissements]
car j'aime aussi je suis sûr que vous
l'attendiez la petite histoire de nelson
cacher c'est que certains vous ne
m'aviez pas du tout prévenu bah oui mon
coach ne sont pas suivies sont pas
prévenus qui viennent alors c'est une
histoire vraie imaginez-vous ce je ne
savais pas que j'avais la justice
thouars vrai qui est arrivée à
buckingham en 1995 la reine d'angleterre
recevait les cheveux les à l'ancien
président aval pour le résident polonais
de l'époque qui était un ancien des
chantiers navals de gdansk pour qu'il
n'était pas la personne la plus
sophistiquée qui soit elle veut lui
faire le grand le grand traitement elle
l'accueille à buckingham sur le palm à
lalonde que vous connaissez carrosse
royal
les chevaux etc ils sont des deux la
reine hélène véry zad dans le carrosse
royal et vous allez croire ou pas cette
histoire ce qui est histoire est vraie à
un moment donné l'un des chevaux l'achat
la chapelle aussi un port d'oran que
bruyant et la reine dit à alès va les as
rome soc arm et ce sous-entendu excuses
le cheval est très haut avec son accent
un peu polonais anglais aux deux matchs
restants t3 d'europe
je pensais que c'était le cheval
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
salut tout l'histoire histoire